Dragons samurai and Keanu Reaves 47
Ronin stars Keanu Reeves as an outcast
amongst this samurai clan he was found
by them as a very young boy they raised
him but they don't really respect him
and when this new evil ruler takes over
their kingdom and banishes all the
samurais
they had to go find Keanu Reeves who's
now been sold into slavery and unite
with him to have revenge against this
guy who's ruined their entire kingdom
and disgraced their former master the
forty-seven Ronin is one of the most
classic tales of Japan's history and I'm
a big fan of the country of Japan and
its culture and just the way it looks
it's a really beautiful country not just
the city aspects of it but I'm talking
about the countryside of Japan looks
beautiful and that's definitely one of
the biggest pros of this movie it looks
really cool the CGI is really good the
3d was very good and the countryside of
Japan looks gorgeous on screen and that
is one of the biggest pros of this film
for sure now as I said this is a very
famous tale of Japan a lot of people pay
their respects to these 47 Ronin each
year in Japan this movie doesn't really
take it seriously this is an
Americanized entertainment version of
that tale with CGI dragons and witches
and a lot of critics had hated on the
film for that a lot of people have said
the film is a whitewashed Americanized
version of this where we have a big
white hero that we're supposed to care
about and all that stuff people get
really up in arms about that kind of
thing which I can understand I don't
really think this film is as bad as
people are saying it's definitely not
the best movie out there
Keanu Reeves is an actor look I love the
guy he's an awesome guy he's super nice
in interviews I think he's a cool guy
I've liked him in many movies in the
past is he the greatest actor alive most
certainly not however he is a very good
physical actor and he can really sell an
action role which he does very well in
this movie a lot of the swordplay was
great his fight scenes look great the
guy is really good at fight scenes I
mean he's obviously proved that well
with his matrix experience it's not one
of his worst performances or anything I
really like Keanu Reeves I'm sorry he's
a cool guy one of the things I did like
about the movie was that his character
was never viewed above the samurai
he was always bowing before them he was
very respectful and he was generally
looked down upon by that culture as well
because of his different race the fact
that it
one of them it's not just I'm the
American guy Keanu Reeves and I'm the
leader of this movie no he really was
just a team member and I really like
that because a lot of people led me to
believe based on their reviews that it
was like the big white American guy who
leads this other country the movie does
have some really cool fight scenes some
cool CGI but the cons of this movie are
is that you really don't care about any
of the characters no one in this movie
really feels important there are certain
aspects of the film where you can tell
that the actors were really serious
about their roles and that they were
doing their best to honor this story but
the CGI element of it that doesn't
really honor the story and that takes it
into this kind of fantasy element didn't
really feel like it meshed with the more
realistic samurai tale which is kind of
what I wanted to see but the other thing
is that everyone speaks English there's
not one single subtitled seeing this
movie which is completely unrealistic
which leads me to another problem
there's a few performances in this movie
that are truly awful namely the witch
character in this film her accent is
appalling and I'm sorry but she was just
awful in this movie also the movie has
an oddly forgettable quality almost
instantly I didn't care anymore when the
movie ended it's a perfectly watchable
movie I think this is a very good rental
a movie that you could just pick up one
day and watch and waste some time with
it's not a great movie it's not a
terrible movie I don't think it's as bad
as some critics are saying yes it
doesn't fully respect that legend in
that tale at the same time it was a well
directed film it looked very good they
did a great job with a lot of the fight
scenes and Keanu Reeves was enjoyable to
watch is it a great movie not really
though I'm gonna have to give 47 Ronin a
C+ now if you do want to see a great
samurai film starring a white dude I
would check out the Last Samurai this is
a very good movie and one of my favorite
samurai films so guys tomorrow is
Christmas I really only have time to see
one movie I asked you guys on Facebook
and Twitter and by far the majority of
people wanted me to see Walter Mitty
so I will go see Walter Mitty tomorrow
and have a review for you guys then I
will put up my best in worst of the year
videos after I have seen the films of
this year that I am going to be watching
guys thanks so much for watching and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck Manoj